un après-midi studieux pour kathleen et
ninon ces deux étudiantes en troisième
année de droit à l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines ont participé
ce jeudi 6 avril à un speed meeting
une rencontre entre élèves et
professionnels dans la faculté
l'occasion pour elle de trouver des
réponses sur leur choix d'orientation
pour l'année prochaine c'est une super
bonne idée parce que du coup ça nous ça
nous rassure en tant qu'étudiant parce
qu'on n'est pas forcément sûr de soi et
ça nous précise un peu notre projet en
fait ça nous appuient notre projet futur
bas on est pas mal perdu surtout en 3e
année parce qu'ils ont choisi le master
est aussi trouvé être sûr de son projet
donc forcément mais perdu mais ouais ça
est bassement à 3,9
un concept imaginé par le bureau des
étudiants impulsion depuis deux ans les
membres ont travaillé pendant trois mois
sur cette édition 2010 est pas ça ne
veut vraiment nous est venue du fait que
même nous on s'est rendu compte
conseille vraiment pas quoi faire après
que souvent on vient en droit pur avec
une des particulière magistrats avocats
profs etc et au final on change
complètement parce que il ya une matière
qui nous intéressait plus qu'une autre
au lycée on apprend absolument pas les
mêmes choses au total douze intervenants
spécialisés dans le droit ont répondu à
l'annonce du bd eux chaque étudiant a pu
s'entretenir individuellement pendant
des dizaines de minutes avec eux en tout
cas ça leur permet
de trier le bon grain de l'ivraie de
savoir un petit peu mieux 2 si bien plus
facilement ceux qui voudront faire plus
tard peut-être faire autre chose mais
d'avoir un panorama plus large avec
peut-être plus d'esprit critique ici que
en cours sur les différents métiers
disponibles et le bureau des étudiants
de compte pas s'arrêter là
une nouvelle édition devrait être
organisée l'année prochaine